fresh off of the boat racing and beat
down of the tampa bay buccaneers
and their pirate ship uh cameron jordan
how are you cam
i'm great um you know it's a victory
monday but
we've already uh we've already finished
dissecting our uh our film and come on
you know we're already we're already
headed on to the next game which
which is the niners hold on a second
when did you land when did you get back
into new orleans
that is a great question i think we
landed somewhere around two this morning
okay
and then uh you know drive home so i
think i walked through the door about
220.
yep and then you know you still got your
energy high you're you know you've got
all that adrenaline still pumping
through the veins so i think we went to
bed about 3 45
4. then you get to work what time do you
get to work oh
8 15. okay it might have been a little
late this morning and you've already
reviewed the film of last night that's
already been done yeah oh yeah
me and me and the d-line we uh we took
that down you know we uh
because of covet i don't think we're
allowed to i don't think we're allowed
to meet as a team or something along the
lines which is cool
right we've still got to break down this
film you know we still got to get better
ricky still got to get pick up breakfast
you know this tradition well
before we turn the page uh we have yet
to turn the pages
a show and uh a national media um
let's let's discuss let's discuss
what were you able to do last night that
you are most proud of
as a unit cam um get pressure on tom
brady from the first nap
you know where i i was trying to get a
good good hit on the uh on the ball over
we all know tom releases the ball as
fast as they come
um to you know the last couple players
where you saw trey henderson
go attack and then you know the attack
was taken away by penalty too
i thought me and him split a sack to him
getting another sack
uh all in series to you know malcolm
malcolm brown get getting us
getting a sack on his old quarterback
coming from the patriot um
and you know it was just one of those
things where david onymata seemed like
he had
12 pressures last night um i thought you
know i thought we did a phenomenal job
of really
uh getting out of the quarterback um
shout out to the d-line and
you talk about the you know dbs coming
up oh dave daniela interception
from you know marcus marcus davenport
bad ball two
i i tipped the ball too
i hold the line had a hand in the plate
no it looked like to me to me that
looked like a like a volleyball play you
know what i mean
like you know what i mean like it was
like yes it did
it really did that and then you know
obviously
um you guys as a unit were able to put
it over the net and
so how repeatable is this cameron how
how good
how is that the best we've seen or you
said you can get better
how repeatable is this i mean
in my mind you know i'd like to say this
this is a new standard
um realistically you know we always just
striving to be one percent better every
day
um you know you can't go into a game
knowing that they're only going to run
the ball
five times for what eight yards nine
yards
somebody's going to have to run you know
the idea of a game plan they're going to
run more than that
normally um especially when you go
against
talented teams uh like the bucks are you
know with all the weapons
that they have um i think we just played
a hell of a game
last night um so would i i'd love her to
be the new norm though if
if if it becomes a sack party and you
know and the db's come up with the
interceptions like they did
i take it every time cameron jordan here
on the rich eisen show five-time pro
bowler after
as i said boat racing the tampa bay
buccaneers on sunday night football
uh walk me into the locker room
afterwards the satisfaction level
was what what was that scene like walk
me in there
from last night um that was it was a
party it was uh
you know winning anytime you win it
doesn't matter how they come
uh when that w goes up in the column
it's something that you've worked hard
all week for
something that you worked all off season
for um the name of the game is winning
and when you're winning you know things
are good and you have to put that in
perspective i mean what was it was it
great to see sean dancing absolutely
um was it great to see james eating a
dub
i don't know but was it was it a
phenomenal feeling
being a part of the uh being part of the
team and winning that's that's a feeling
that you can't get over
well you know the famed eating a w if
i'm not mistaken took place
in the superdome many years ago and now
he's doing it
uh in celebration of what happened uh
against his former team so
even now it's still something that
needs a little bit of an arm twist for
you to say is fine and cool
is that did i just pick that up camera
uh you gotta
embrace and embrace uh and
embrace a situation yes
okay so it's you know uh it's something
that you still need uh
i guess a little bit more mustard on
that or less mustard essentially is what
you're saying
you know uh you can't you can't hide
from it you have to embrace it if you're
james you know and
uh as a teammate i do nothing but uh
support you know my brother in arms so
if my guy eats a dub i'd say he hated
dumb okay i don't know
you know i will i would love i would
love to if
if he eats a dub every week and we're
winning every week let's go
let's go all right i'll i'll watch him
eat his plate well we saw the return
of michael thomas last night but you
also are getting guys on your side of
the ball back as well what does marcus
davenport's return mean
uh for you and you mentioned trey
hendrickson who's playing his head off
lately what what
what about that and how you can
use it moving forward i mean marcus
really had some great pressures from the
interior
i mean when you talk about uh three
defensive ends being on the field i mean
nobody's gonna be more excited about
that than myself
and then of course you know you talked
about coming back
and playing the run well then on third
down he slid down into the interior and
created some
some havoc along with david onyamata um
and of course like
like you just said trey henderson is
playing you know playing out of his mind
right now
if i'm gonna catch a double you catch a
single win you're single you got to win
your singles and even last night when i
was catching singles
it was you know it was it was a race to
the quarterback and that's what you love
to see
and obviously you know um we know about
goat and goat conversation brady and
breeze and
all that stuff you taking brady out on
behalf of
your team obviously is significant but
what about on behalf of brees
um you know nothing's going to tell me
that you know drew brees isn't the
greatest quarterback of all times i mean
you talk about you know have you know
him and tom brady fighting for the
record the most touchdowns you talk
about
you know drew clearly having more yards
in his career you talk about how many
five thousand yard seasons he's put
together
um you could also you know he's five
five thousand seasons he talked about
you know
brady and his six six championship rings
that's undisputable there
um so if you talk about stats and what
goes go through
drew's the goat let's talk about you
know most championships winning
tom brady's the goat so you have the
argument for one and two
i'ma stick to my drew being being number
one
and uh thomas being back means what
oh man i mean mike t yep he's he's
special
anytime you touch the field and not only
did we get my key back you got amanda
sanders back yeah she did
you saw i mean you saw you know drew
with more weapons
it's a beautiful thing are you the best
team in the nfl
i mean what do you expect me to say here
rich
week in week out we're striving to be as
best as we can be i will say we are
we're trending upwards
i've always considered myself and our
team to
be the best that we can be um so i'll
leave the media to label however they
will we're just going to keep on working
and go for this message with the w
well i'll tell you cameron i mean i like
to take it one segment at a time and
hope for the best
i like to feel like i'm bringing my a
game to the microphone every single day
and i know there's amazing
uh shows on this very channel as well uh
following dan patrick's show every
single day but i'll i'll say i've got
the best show on television uh
right you know right you know like what
do you want me to say if i'm asked do
you have the best show
on television uh yeah are you supposed
to say anything less you're always
supposed to think that
you know whatever you're doing you're
putting your your best foot forward
right and i could say you know what they
have a great segment here they have a
great team there they've got a great
host there they you know uh dan's got
marconi's
probably plural but you know i'll i'll
still i'll still throw my marker down
you know what i mean hey verse anyone i
love us if you like it i love it
okay no i heard you on i still love it
do you tell dan the same thing when
you're on his show
uh absolutely if he asked if things are
the best thing
i'm trying i'm testing your trust level
right now cameron
[Laughter]
that's what i'm doing i'm just big i'm
trying to find it
what's who's uh who's on your podcast
next what are you doing
um you know with me and mark we we've
got a couple guys i think we're we're
supposed to settle on who who are
releasing this week
uh today so uh i i would i will know in
the next hour you know we've got we've
got we've got star study cast we still
got some heavy haters
that we can release you know um between
me and mark
we we seem to know a few guys across the
league i noticed you had lamar
so um so these are in the can are you
doing them during the
during the week at all or no you you did
this before the season and you're you're
releasing them once a week is that what
it is or what are you doing i've
we we recorded most of them uh
pre-season so when
when tango was football right um and
then during bye week we we
we knocked uh we're gonna knock one out
or knock one out okay
um so we'll see what happens postseason
you know if we get if we get a week
we're going to turn some episodes uh
well right now you're in the one seed
and there's only one bye week so
uh that would be very good for you
congrats on that congrats on that
congrats on that w last night um and uh
i guess
eating it um and um and
uh and i guess what's the last what's
tougher uh to
achieve what you did last night or to go
home to your kids on short rest and them
not caring and you having to be present
for them
oh yeah my uh my son it was was
definitely up at
six o'clock this morning i just heard
footsteps um you know but uh
with kobe i sort of now use extra
conscience you know i sleep i sleep in a
completely different room like everybody
sees upstairs i see downstairs
you know just try to protect the family
so i get a point of care con
point of care test the next uh the next
day so once i get that i come back home
and now it's then it's pure dad time
but uh they're up they're up regardless
keep doing that cameron stay
healthy stay healthy and keep doing what
you're doing um
it's always great chatting with you
thanks for the call after such a big w
um and um and lack of rest and all the
covid and all the craziness
i really appreciate you taking the time
always always appreciate for having me
like
i feel like i feel like i'm part of the
crew you are cameron jordan
you absolutely are go give him a round
of applause just make sure he's a
totally understanding
take care of yourself you be well okay
that's cameron jordan everybody